Нестача газу через Росію - Федеральна
мережева агенція шукає шляхи економії
Падіння популярності AfD -
пошук спільної лінії на з'їзді партії
Літня хвиля коронавірусу -
уряд готується до осені
В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман і Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Добрий вечір усім.
Над адміністративними будівлями в Україні
тепер майорить не лише
державний стяг, а й прапор ЄС.
Українці переконані, що обрали правильний шлях.
Країна й справді
пройшла сьогодні перше випробування.
«Так, Україна заслуговує на європейське майбутнє.
Так, Україну слід вітати як країну-кандидата.
Адже були зроблені правильні кроки,
проте попереду ще багато
не менш важливої роботи».
Інакше кажучи, попереду ще багато випробувань.
Передусім - час. Український народ
відділяють від європейської мрії,
можливо, ще багато років, ба навіть десятиліть,
якщо все йтиме, як раніше.
Та, можливо, як раніше, вже не буде.
Наразі взагалі залишається
багато питань без відповідей.
«Напружена» - так Федеральна мережева агенція
сьогодні вперше схарактеризувала ситуацію з
постачанням газу в Німеччину.
Напружені також і нерви в усіх нас.
Ціни на газ для приватних домогосподарств
вже зросли в кілька разів
порівняно з довоєнними
і вони й надалі лізтимуть вгору.
Наразі Росія значно скорочує постачання газу.
Президент Володимир Путін переконаний,
що він переможе в боротьбі за енергію,
і взагалі говорить про новий світоустрій.
Подробиці - в сюжеті Пітера Кунца.
Між Володимиром Путіним й Заходом
є величезна різниця,
як і між Заходом та уявленням
президента Росії про нього.
Потужний словесний напад
лунає на Санкт-Петербурзькому міжнародному
економічному форумі -
такий собі аналог Давосу в його світі.
США, які вважають себе переможцями
у Холодній війні,
посланцями Божими на землі,
які не мають обов'язків,
лише інтереси, які вони вважають священними.
Путін засуджує, що країни Заходу
ставляться до інших, як до колоній,
але, мовляв, світ змінюється.
Економічний бліцкриг проти Росії не вдався -
про це заявив сьогодні Путін.
І справді картинка Росії під санкціями
дещо інша, ніж може здаватися відразу.
Рубль зміцнів, як ніколи за останні роки,
а зростання цін на нафту і газ
принесли величезні прибутки.
Росія провокує нестабільність
на міжнародному ринку газу
й надалі підвищує ціни,
скорочуючи або припиняючи
постачання газу у країни Європи,
зокрема у Польщу, Болгарію, Данію,
Фінляндію, Нідерланди,
Німеччину, Італію, Австрію,
а тепер також у Словаччину та Францію.
Президент Росії не відчуває збитків від того,
що Москва скорочує постачання газу європейцям.
Їх компенсує, зокрема, політична вигода.
За зиму без опалення має перейматися
передусім Німеччина.
Ми підготувалися до цієї ситуації,
передусім ухвалюючи необхідні закони,
наприклад, закон про наповнення газосховищ,
та шукаючи можливості
використовувати інші види палива.
Звісно, варто зазначити,
що розвиток відновних джерел енергії і
короткострокова економія енергії прямо зараз
дуже допомагає поліпшити ситуацію.
Економити за будь-якої можливості
й докуповувати газ з усіх можливих джерел.
У світі немає дефіциту газу,
його лише треба доставити в Німеччину,
яка дуже сильно залежить від російського газогону,
цю залежність можна порівняти з наркотичною,
і, на відміну від сусідніх європейських країн,
не має інфраструктури для зрідженого газу,
тож нині бореться за постачання.
Німеччина отримує газ,
але якщо різні країни залучають
різні джерела постачання,
тоді виникає конкуренція.
Тому дуже важливо
узгоджувати дії європейських країн,
щоб об'єднати наші зусилля,
а не намагатися обігнати одне одного.
Путінське яблуко розбрату -
щоб перешкодити планам очільника Кремля,
газосховища Німеччини,
як-от найбільше в країні,
розташоване в Редені, Нижня Саксонія,
потрібно заповнити до осені.
Боротися зі штучним підвищенням цін Росією
має допомогти програма кредитного фінансування.
Уряд анонсував великий пакет
фінансової допомоги,
масштабну програму підтримки
платоспроможності населення,
це правильний крок.
Однак потрібно буде ретельно проаналізувати,
чи отримають допомогу найбільш вразливі, ті,
кому вона необхідна,
та чи потрібні інші пакети допомоги для тих,
хто взимку опиниться в дійсно
скрутному фінансовому становищі.
Найгарячіша тема літа -
як ми всі грітимемося наступної зими?
Над питаннями дефіциту газу,
який загрожує Німеччині,
працює Федеральна мережева агенція в Бонні,
яку очолює Клаус Мюллер.
Добрий вечір, пане Мюллер.
Вітаю, пане Зіверс.
Росія скоротила постачання газу
через «Північний потік-1» до 40%,
як вона стверджує,
через ремонт компресорних турбін.
Вочевидь, їх дійсно треба ремонтувати,
тож чи справді це може бути причиною?
Ці турбіни потрібно регулярно обслуговувати,
іноді ремонтувати - це правда.
Та ми не бачимо причин чи взаємозв'язку,
який би виправдав скорочення постачань на 60%.
Тому для нас таке пояснення не є переконливим.
Тож тут радше політична мотивація. Чи впорається
країна, якщо й надалі отримуватиме лише 40%?
Саме через це
Федеральна мережева агенція сьогодні вперше
повідомила про «напружену ситуацію».
Ми отримуємо приблизно
на 1000 гВт·год на добу менше.
Це стосується не лише Німеччини, але й країн,
через які ми перекачуємо газ далі,
зокрема й згадана Франція.
Загалом ми отримуємо значно менше газу,
і наші газосховища
заповнені не настільки,
як нам це вдавалося
впродовж останніх днів і тижнів.
І це проблема, адже ми планували
заповнити їх на 90% і більше.
Чи можемо ми заповнити їх на 90% і більше
у теперішній ситуації?
Хороше запитання. Якби я знав, то спав би міцніше.
У нас склалася ситуація,
коли ми отримуємо менше газу
і не знаємо, скільки надійде у сховища.
Ми бачимо зростання цін,
це не покращує становище.
Через це також скорочується споживання газу.
Тож відбувається кілька протилежних процесів,
і я не можу Вам відповісти, але можу запевнити,
що ми робимо все,
що в наших силах, щоб досягти мети.
Якби нам навіть вдалося
повністю заповнити газосховища,
чи вистачило б цього на зиму?
Це теж хороше запитання.
Якщо газосховища будуть заповнені на 100%,
то це задовольнить
потреби Німеччини приблизно на 2 місяці
за умов середньостатистичної зими
у випадку, якщо необхідно буде повністю
відмовитися від російського газу.
Та хто знає, коли зима почнеться й закінчиться,
наскільки холодною буде?
Невідомо, чи будемо ми в скрутному становищі
і чи дотримуватимуться наші європейські сусіди
в цьому випадку солідарного зобов'язання?
Занадто багато невідомих, і ніхто не може
робити серйозних прогнозів.
Проте ми вже зараз закликаємо:
кожний заощаджений кубометр газу
матиме позитивні наслідки для клімату, гаманця
та профілактики скрутного становища.
Тому ми просимо підприємців і споживачів
робити все можливе.
Ви так просите, що підприємці малюють
в уяві жахливі сценарії: брак газу
спричинить крах цілих галузей промисловості.
Як Ви оцінюєте таку можливість?
Промисловість впорається з цим
чи вже є загроза справжньої катастрофи?
На жаль, це дуже залежить від того,
що відбуватиметься
найближчими тижнями й місяцями.
Приблизно за 12 тижнів
починається опалювальний сезон.
Наразі важко думати про економію газу
з огляду на літні температурні показники.
Однак 3 місяці швидко минуть.
Якщо уряд Німеччини оголосить
надзвичайну ситуацію через дефіцит газу,
у разі якої застосовується
європейське законодавство,
тоді Федеральній мережевій
агенції доведеться втрутитися.
Ми б не хотіли чіпати особливо
вразливі групи споживачів,
як-от приватні домогосподарства, лікарні, будинки опіки
для людей літнього віку і людей з обмеженими можливостями,
але галузі промисловості, підприємства за певних умов
нам доведеться відключити
від системи споживання газу, адже його
просто не вистачатиме.
Тому уряд Німеччини робить все,
щоб знайти нові джерела постачання.
Наприклад, вже згадані термінали
зрідженого природного газу:
якби нам цієї зими вдалося отримати
ще два термінали, це б дуже допомогло.
Ви щойно сказали, що не будете чіпати
приватні домогосподарства, принаймні не в першу чергу.
Чи Ви припускаєте, що люди
замерзатимуть у своїх квартирах?
Я можу Вас запевнити, що ми зробимо все,
щоб цього не сталося.
Саме тому я терміново звертаюся до всіх і
прошу серйозно сприймати
цю терміновість у моєму голосі:
все, що ви можете заощадити зараз,
навіть у літні місяці,
допоможе нам.
Звертати увагу на температуру опалення восени -
це теж нам допоможе.
Це стосується й промисловості.
Ми закликаємо подумати,
де можна залучити інші види палива.
У Бундестазі обговорюють
ініціювання закону щодо скорочення
використання газу
і його заміни на вугілля.
Ми вже згадували про зріджений газ.
Уряд Німеччини вже робить дуже багато, промисловість
і приватні домогосподарства
можуть допомогти Німеччині пережити цю зиму,
яка, як би нам не хотілося, але все одно наступить.
Це правда, і ми також чуємо терміновість
у Вашому голосі.
Пане Мюллер, якщо підсумувати все,
що Ви щойно сказали,
то Володимир Путін досі має значні важелі впливу
в усьому, що стосується енергетики?
У цьому випуску Ви
досить жорстко висловилися про залежність,
пов'язану з наркотичною субкультурою,
з якою Ви порівняли Німеччину.
Справа в тому, що Німеччина досі є залежною.
Уряд Німеччини, міністр Роберт Габек роблять усе,
аби ми були менш залежними від викопного палива
та російського газу.
Це добре для захисту клімату,
для попередження скрутних ситуацій, для нашого гаманця.
Але щоб позбутися цієї залежності нам потрібен час.
І, ймовірно, більше часу,
ніж залишилось до наступної зими.
І тому я кажу, що ми перебуваємо
в напруженій ситуації.
Клаус Мюллер, голова Федеральної мережевої агенції.
Напевно, це наша не остання розмова.
Дякую і до побачення!
Також щодо економіки:
більшість німців очікує низхідний тренд.
Лише 22% громадян характеризують
економічну ситуацію в Німеччині як хорошу,
що є найнижчим показником за останні 12 років.
Одразу після нас в ефірі «ZDF-Politbarometer»
з усією статистикою.
Ситуація на з'їздах партії AfD
традиційно дуже нестабільна.
Навіть коли йдеться про обрання
нового керівництва партії,
графік обговорень непередбачуваний.
На завтрашньому з'їзді партії в місті Різа
вперше можуть обрати лише одного політика,
який самостійно очолюватиме партію.
Давід Гебгардт розповість про це детальніше.
Тіно Хрупалла знає, що йому потрібні союзники,
щоб після з'їзду партії в Різі
залишитися на посаді очільника.
Останнім часом справи йшли не дуже добре:
невтішні результати на 10 виборах у землях
та на федеральному рівні, менше членів партії,
закріпився імідж партії як безідейної та такої,
що завжди виступає проти.
Як Ви поясните те,
що під час останніх 10-ти виборів ми втратили
майже 20% виборців?
Члени партії вийшли з її рядів,
бо були абсолютно невдоволені політичним
та програмним керівництвом
цієї партії впродовж останнього року чи двох років.
Лідерство можна отримати через компетентність,
і варто відверто сказати, що ми самі себе підвели.
Тим часом з'їзд партії перетворюється
на майданчик для боротьби.
Пригнічений настрій у членів партії,
яка переживає кризу сенсу.
Жодного виграшного питання,
постійні внутрішньопартійні суперечки,
Тіно Хрупалла закликає до перезавантаження.
Сьогодні ми разом намагаємось позбутися
руйнівних настроїв минулого.
На цьому з'їзді ми маємо обрати
федеральне правління партії,
яке працюватиме колегіально та конструктивно,
тактовно, ґрунтуючись на довірі.
Виборці мають бачити нашу згуртованість,
бо виборці ненавидять, коли цієї згуртованості немає,
і ненавидять вони небезпідставно.
Дрібка самокритики від двох очільників фракцій,
які завтра хочуть бути обраними разом
до керівництва партії:
або як два рівноправні очільники, або Аліс Вайдель
як перша заступниця Хрупалли.
Ухвалена сьогодні поправка до статуту партії
вперше уможливить одноосібне очільництво партії.
Але багато членів не довіряють Тіно Хрупаллі
як єдиному очільнику.
Ми уможливлюємо вибір між одноосібним
та колегіальним очільництвом.
Ми закріплюємо це в Статуті.
Цього разу ми ще обиратимемо двох очільників.
Вимагає обрання двох очільників
правий екстреміст Бйорн Гокке,
який, ймовірно, і цього разу ухиляється
від висування своєї кандидатури,
щоб іншими способами розширити
свою політичну міць
в тіні Хрупалли та Вайдель.
А запобігти цьому хоче Норберт Кляйнвехтер -
один із щонайменше двох кандидатів-опонентів
на посаду очільника партії.
Кляйнвехтера вважають більш поміркованим,
а його обрання досить малоймовірне.
Це рішення, що визначатиме партійну лінію.
Партія має стати більш приємною та доброзичливою,
бо навіть під час виборчої кампанії помітно,
що нас часто сприймають
недостатньо приємними ﻿та доброзичливими.
Тому нам варто працювати над нашим іміджем.
Отже, завтра партія AfD обере керівництво.
Пророкують, що це буде запекла боротьба.
Партію очікують великі зміни.
Ханна розповість нам про ще одного важливого політика,
який завітав сьогодні до Маріїнського палацу в Києві.
У Києві побував прем'єрміністр Великої Британії
Борис Джонсон.
Він пообіцяв подальшу військову допомогу
президентові України Зеленському
і запропонував для українських військових
програму навчання з користування новою зброєю.
На зустрічі Джонсон заявив, що він підтримує Україну
та планує забезпечити стратегічну витривалість України,
якої вона потребує.
Це вже другий візит Бориса Джонсона до Києва
з початку війни.
Після багаторічної юридичної тяганини
уряд Великої Британії схвалив ﻿екстрадицію ﻿до США
засновника порталу «WikiLeaks» Джуліана Ассанжа.
Його адвокати хочуть оскаржити це рішення.
Колишньому керівнику платформи, на якій
оприлюднювали секретні матеріали,
загрожує до 175 років позбавлення волі в США.
Його звинувачують у тому,
що він допоміг вкрасти секретні матеріали
щодо військових операцій США.
Прихильники Ассанжа вважають його журналістом,
який викрив та оприлюднив інформацію
про воєнні злочини.
Через 4 дні після оприлюднення дослідження
щодо сексуального насильства в єпархії Мюнстера
єпископ Фелікс Ґенн прокоментував звинувачення.
Фелікс Ґенн визнав помилки,
однак відмовився піти у відставку
та заявив, що нічого не приховував.
Він також повідомив про наслідки:
кадрові рішення мають бути прозорішими,
необхідним є створення комісії,
яка розглядатиме це питання.
Згідно з дослідженням, з 1945 до 2020 року
в єпархії Мюнстера 610 хлопчиків і дівчаток
стали жертвами сексуального насильства
з боку священнослужителів.
У Шверині розпочала роботу
парламентська комісія з розслідування,
яка вивчатиме діяльність
сумнівного фонду «Захист клімату і довкілля»
землі Мекленбург-Передня Померанія.
Фонд підтримував як проєкти із захисту клімату,
так і завершення будівництва
німецько-російського газопроводу «Північний потік-2».
Комісія має з'ясувати, зокрема,
обставини створення фонду
та роль прем'єрміністерки Мануели Швезіґ.
З'ясувати мають також, як на це впливала Росія
та куди витрачали гроші, що надавала Москва.
Клопотання подали партії CDU, Зелені і FDP.
Сьогодні в Німеччині вшановували пам'ять загиблих
під час народного повстання 17 червня 1953 року в НДР.
У Берліні бургомістерка Франциска Ґіффай
та міністерка у справах будівництва Клара Ґайвіц
поклали вінки на кладовищіЗеєштрассе.
69 років тому приблизно мільйон жителів НДР
вийшли на вулиці на знак протесту
за покращення умов життя та вільні вибори.
Повстання було криваво придушене
радянськими військовими.
Понад 50 людей були вбиті та тисячі заарештовані.
«День бабака» - назва американської кінокомедії,
головний герой якої застряг у часовій петлі.
Про цей фільм згадуєш щоразу,
коли міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини
на пресконференціях
повідомляє, що може трапитися восени.
До речі, хоч би як звали міністра охорони здоров'я,
це завжди тривожні заклики,
попередження та оголошення,
що треба бути підготовленим.
Занадто часто ми стаємо свідками того,
якою непідготовленою є країна, коли починається
наступна хвиля захворювань.
Сьогодні, однак, все інакше.
Хоч міністр охорони здоров'я знову виступає
із тривожними закликами та оголошеннями,
він також застерігає від паніки.
І він обіцяє,
що цього разу все буде інакше, ніж раніше.
Детальніше - Франк Бухвальд.
Настало літо, люди насолоджуються сонцем,
зітхають з полегшенням.
І це не дивно, адже ми пережили 2,5 роки пандемії.
Але на федеральній пресконференції
міністр охорони здоров'я Німеччини
нагадав, що вірус нікуди не зник.
Наразі показники захворюваності
не дозволяють нам зробити носіння маски обов'язковим,
але якщо ви хочете захистити себе та інших,
тоді вам слід носити маску.
Тому я звертаюся до населення із проханням
захистити себе та інших.
Нові підтипи штаму «Омікрон» - ВА.4 та ВА.5 - заразні,
але менш небезпечні.
Про це повідомляє міністр, а тому
покладається на добровільні захисні заходи.
Незгоду висловлюють громади на місцях.
Добровільність цих заходів - це добре,
але зараз не допоможе.
Але якщо показники справді зростуть,
громада повинна отримати право
впроваджувати такі зобов'язання.
Інститут Роберта Коха RKI
очікує зростання рівня захворюваності
найближчими тижнями.
Критику, що RKI фіксує не всі випадки,
відхиляє віцепрезидент Ларс Шааде.
У нас є необхідні дані з усіх основних питань.
Але ці дані потрібно правильно інтерпретувати
та розглядати їх у контексті.
Кількість випадків коронавірусу то зменшується,
то збільшується.
Не так важливо,
чи семиденний показник захворюваності 600 чи 495.
Важливою є сама тенденція.
Наступного року міністр Карл Лаутербах
очікує на появу нових вакцин,
які могли б повністю запобігти зараженню.
Ми все дедалі ближче до того часу,
коли вдасться розробити вакцини,
адаптовані до вірусів,
які дозволять запобігти зараженню,
що також створить базовий імунітет у населення,
а коронавірус стане таким самим захворюванням,
як і будь-яка інша інфекційна хвороба.
Але ми ще не дійшли до цього.
Восени таких вакцин ще не буде.
За словами міністра, людям похилого віку
і тим, хто перебуває в групі ризику,
слід зробити четверте щеплення вже зараз.
Тому я рекомендую зробити четверте щеплення тим,
хто підпадає під рекомендації
Постійної комісії з вакцинації STIKO, -
людям віком від 70 років
та тим, хто має супутні захворювання.
Але й іншим я б також рекомендував не відмовлятися
від можливості вакцинуватися.
Наприклад, я вакцинувався вчетверте,
бо багато контактую з іншими людьми.
У вересні Карл Лаутербах планує
представити новий закон «Про захист
від інфекційних хвороб»
з суворішими вимогами щодо носіння масок.
Проте більше не буде спроб
зробити вакцинацію обов'язковою.
Експертна комісія має надати детальну інформацію
наприкінці червня.
Цю тему ми обговорюватимо далі.
Розглянемо одне з головних спірних питань,
яке виникало у часи, коли вакцини від коронавірусу
все ще були в дефіциті в усьому світі.
Чи треба скасовувати патентний захист
вакцин від коронавірусу?
Сьогодні Світова організація торгівлі (СОТ)
прийняла рішення щодо цього і заявила,
що патенти можна обійти, принаймні тимчасово.
Валері Галлер,
є багато критики щодо такого рішення,
причому з різних напрямків.
Чому саме?
Тому що це компроміс,
тут можна знайти критиків з обох сторін.
Це, звичайно, не зовсім великий успіх.
Результат явно відстає від первісної пропозиції.
І все ж таки це успіх для СОТ.
Роками обговорення теми були запеклими.
У Женеві велика радість серед членів СОТ.
Вперше за багато років торговельна організація
знову досягла угоди.
Угода була успішною за важливим пунктом:
патенти на вакцини проти коронавірусу.
Фармацевтичні компанії на деякий час
відмовляються від своїх патентів,
що дозволить виробникам у бідних регіонах,
таких як Африка, масово виробляти вакцини.
Критики з організації «Лікарі без кордонів»
та інших некомерційних організацій кажуть,
що угода не охоплює більш радикальні пропозиції,
запропоновані раніше.
Вона діє строком лише до 5 років і
є запізнілою.
Справді, зараз вакцин набагато більше,
ніж це необхідно.
Зняття патентного захисту стосується лише вакцин,
а не інших товарів для лікування і діагностики.
А фармацевтичні компанії
висловлюють своє розчарування.
Роками компанії інвестують в дослідження,
і лише частина з них виявляється успішною.
Патентний захист гарантує,
що фармакомпанії зароблятимуть гроші на своїй продукції
протягом багатьох років, тому для них
така угода - це небезпечний сигнал.
Дякую, Валері з Франкфурта.
До тенісу: професіонал Кубка Девіса
Оскар Отте несподівано вийшов у півфінал
на турнірі на траві в Галле, Вестфалія.
28-річний спортсмен виграв
у росіянина Хачанова у чвертьфіналі.
І це після програшу в першому сеті.
Завтра №2 з Німеччини зустрінеться
з Медведєвим - №1 в світовому рейтингу,
трансляція на каналі ZDF з 14:15.
Він був однією з великих зірок французького кіно:
актор Жан-Луї Трентіньян помер у віці 91.
Він здобув популярність разом з Бріджіт Бардо
у фільмі «І Бог створив жінку».
В 1966 році він здійснив міжнародний прорив
завдяки ролі у фільмі «Чоловік і жінка».
Загалом Трентіньян зіграв понад 140 ролей у кіно
та на телебаченні, навіть у зрілому віці.
Наприклад, у 2012 році
у відзначеній нагородами драмі «Любов».
Таким був наш світ цієї п'ятниці.
А тепер, як повідомлялося раніше,
цікава статистика у випуску «Politbarometer»
з Матіасом Форноффом.
Гарного вечора!
Добрий вечір,
ласкаво просимо до нового випуску «Politbarometer»!
Це був могутній символ підтримки України:
канцлер Шольц, голова уряду Італії Драґі
а також президенти Франції і Румунії,
Макрон та Йоганніс, виступили в Києві за те,
щоб Україна стала кандидатом на членство в ЄС.
Таке рішення прийняла сьогодні і Комісія ЄС.
Більшість німців хотіли б бачити Україну в ЄС.
Подальші поставки зброї, також з Німеччини,
мають допомогти країні
краще захиститися від російського нападу.
Лише 26% опитаних вважають,
що Україна може виграти війну проти Росії
за допомогою тяжкого озброєння із Заходу.
64 % в це не вірять.
З огляду на російську агресію країни НАТО гуртуються,
НАТО стає важливим чинником для громадян.
Явна більшість німців стверджує:
НАТО стало набагато важливішим для безпеки Німеччини.
І майже 8 з 10 громадян вважають,
що було б добре, якби Фінляндія і Швеція
приєдналися до Альянсу.
Більше половини опитаних виступають за те,
щоб НАТО посилило свій східний фланг
в Польщі та країнах Балтії додатковими військами.
38% – проти.
У вересні 2014 року співвідношення було протилежним:
більшість виступила проти посилення східного флангу НАТО.
А на той час Росія вже анексувала Крим
та розв'язала війну на Донбасі.
Таким чином, агресія Путіна змінила
сприйняття та мислення людей.
Солідарність з Україною лишається сильною.
Громадяни також звертають увагу на те,
як уряд у Берліні допомагає урядові в Києві.
43% опитаних задоволені підтримкою України
з боку уряду Німеччини.
Третині цього замало.
А 16% вважають,
що допомога заходить надто далеко.
Уряд «світлофорної» коаліції
при владі трохи більше півроку.
І викликів йому не бракує.
Подивимося на
партійний ландшафт в Німеччині.
Наразі змін там мало.
Якби наступної неділі відбулися вибори до Бундестагу,
то SPD отримала б 22%, CDU/CSU - 26%,
обидві партії без змін.
Зелені отримали б 25%, +1, FDP 6%, -1,
AfD - 10%, без змін
Ліві - 5%, +1.
Від партій до конкретних осіб.
Ось «десятка» найважливіших політиків,
рейтинг за прихильністю опитаних та продуктивністю роботи
за шкалою від +5 до -5.
Внизу списку - Крістіне Ламбрехт,
-0,7, дещо кращий результат.
На 9 місці опинилася Сара Ваґенкнехт, -0,7,
погіршений результат.
Погіршили показники Маркус Зедер і Фрідріх Мерц:
результат обох 0,0.
6 місце - Крістіан Лінднер з 0,1,
результат значно погіршився.
Попереду Карл Лаутербах 0,7 та Джем Оздемір 1,1.
Обидва мають кращий результат.
3-тє місце - Олаф Шольц:
результат без змін 1,1.
Анналена Бербок 1,6, гірше.
Очолює список Роберт Габек,
як і раніше 2,1.
Питання витрат, зарплат, цін
є зараз найважливішою проблемою для німців,
навіть випереджаючи війну в Україні,
хоча звісно ці два питання пов'язані.
Уряд ФРН вжив різних заходів
для допомоги громадянам.
І вони оцінюються дуже по-різному.
Почнемо зі знижки на пальне.
В те, що споживачі повністю відчують знижку на пальне
після зниження енергетичного податку
для нафтових компаній,
мало хто вірить - 8%,
89% очікують, що цього не станеться.
Ціни на рекордно високому рівні,
і не тільки на АЗС.
Більш ніж 8 з 10 опитаних очікують,
що це не кінець
і ціни зростатимуть далі.
Тому німці песимістичні у своїй оцінці
загальної економічної ситуації в країні.
Лише 22% характеризують її як хорошу.
Це найнижчий показник з 2010 року.
Пільговий квиток за 9 євро
має принести деяке полегшення.
Поїздки автобусами та потягами по всій країні
рідко коли були такими дешевими, як зараз.
Майже три чверті опитаних вважають,
що квиток за 9 євро - це хороше рішення.
Лише 23% так не вважає.
Однак мало хто вірить,
що це матиме довгостроковий ефект.
Лише 19% вважають,
що у майбутньому більше людей
користуватиметься автобусами та потягами.
Тобто з вересня, коли квиток за 9 євро
більше не буде доступним.
Це був наш репортаж про настрої в країні.
Як завжди, графіки та всю інформація
про наші опитування
Ви знайдете в текстовій версії ZDF зі сторінки 165,
у додатку ZDFheute і на сайті ZDFheute.de.
Про те, як проводяться репрезентативні опитування
дослідницької групи Wahlen,
інформацію про методологію
та стандарти якості
Ви можете дізнатися на сайті politbarometer.zdf.de.
Дякую, що дивилися.
Наступний «Politbarometer» в ефірі 1 липня.
Після прогнозу погоди випуск «heute show spezial»:
Лутц ван дер Хорст та Фабіан Кестер
з сатирою на CDU.
Гарного вечора!
Доброго вечора та
ласкаво просимо до прогнозу погоди.
Ми озираємося на травень.
Особливо в Європі було дуже тепло,
передусім на південному заході.
Ви можете бачити спеку над Північною Африкою,
яка потім досягла навіть Франції.
Там травень був найспекотнішим і найбільш сухим
з початку метеорологічних спостережень.
Була хвиля спеки, яка принесла
багато тепла на північ.
Така погодна ситуація повториться і в ці дні.
На завтра очікуються найвищі температури.
Спека з Північної Африки йде через Іспанію
до Франції та Німеччини.
Часто буде досягнуто позначки близько 40°,
також і на заході Німеччині.
Вночі на заході проясниться,
у інших регіонах подекуди хмарно.
Температура знизиться до 19° на заході Німеччини
та 10° на південному сході, тому
провітрюйте добре, бо вже завтра буде спекотно.
На півдні дуже сонячно,
в інших регіонах подекуди незначна хмарність, без опадів.
Температура до 39° на південному заході,
частково 38° на заході,
місцями можлива температура до 40°.
На півночі прохолодніше - від 21° до 24°.
У неділю знову 39°, дуже сонячно.
Також пройдуть зливи та грози.
Місцями сильні грози.
Після цього буде не так спекотно.
Гарного вечора.